they put my father in jail for 25 worth
of illegal substance they put him in
jail for seven years oh wow this man was
an educator in the hood in the inner
cities educating kids the judge that he
would have come to the school and talk
to the kids presided over his case and
put him in jail and what they didn't
understand was their father taught me
everything told me how to throw a
football of basketball told me how to
play tennis
and I was like why am I learning how to
play tennis he's because I don't want
you to be limited I told my Pops I I
can't come see you because I see you as
a king
I wrote him a letter
I said hey you know
things have gotten good for me when you
get out I saved your life
and he's been living with me for 20
years now no matter
where you start
you got the opportunity to change if
something great happens just be prepared
for whatever is going to come along I
tell people all the time appreciate the
failures
the real ones never trip you look at
Hendrix you look at Elvis they have to
have something because that's God family
yeah God's gonna give you something
incredible but he's also going to give
you something to Anchor that because I
believe this is what I believe in and
you tell me if you believe this I
believe in the yin and the Yang of
everything meaning like when there's
absolute light there has to be absolute
Darkness to balance it out and that's
what everything that we do it's sort of
like We're Not Gonna Get Away
with anything like anything that happens
to you in life you have to pay for it
like it's like the grocery store okay I
got the career got to pay for that okay
I got the money okay I gotta pay for
that then here come the family yeah I
need that money yeah you you well I'm
going I'm going I'm gonna release a
story about you so it's all of these
different things that you got to pay for
but at the end of the day and I tell
fathers this all the time no matter what
you do is how your your kids turn out
that's what's the most important thing
in the world
that makes you happy what makes me happy
man is seeing the result of you creating
something in your living room or in your
bathroom my idea a joke a song and then
seeing the whole world repeat it I wake
up and do like this mental check system
I'm in this situation I'm in a in a
situation where I'm able to create and
that's my job and then I look at what I
could have been doing
so I turned my light on I said I'm going
to turn my light on no matter where no
matter if I'm tired or if I'm right
whatever it is I turn my light on and
that saves you because a lot of people
turn their lights off when I wake up I
said I'm not gonna be afraid to be goofy
I'm not gonna be afraid to be but I'm
not going to afraid to challenge myself
and it's just a mental thing that you do
when you wake up and then once you do
that and once you learn how to tap into
it you don't need any of the other stuff
I am having a ride in my life it is so
great I wish I could take what I'm
feeling right now and put it in the
Water Systems and everybody could drink
it and we will all love each other a
whole lot more I'm telling you I'm going
to thank Ray Charles I sat with Ray
Charles and I was sitting and I was
playing with him and I hit a wrong note
and he said no why the hell would you do
that
and I said I don't know he said the
notes are right underneath your fingers
he said life is notes right underneath
our fingers all you got to do is take
the time out to play the right notes and
what I tell people is we have to be
Fearless we have to stand up to these
bullies we cannot allow people to
condone this type of uh a behavior and
we cannot let some people uh say that
these people are somehow good people you
know they're they're not and you know we
have to be we have to be steadfast in it
and it's going to be scary I predict in
these next few years the way things are
going it's going to be scary man but
good people good white people good black
people good Hispanic people Asian and
everything in between my Muslim Brothers
I Jewish Brothers all of our brothers
man and sisters
if God Allah Buddha whoever you believe
in
said that we should be here on Earth
that means we're supposed to be here no
one is here because they're not supposed
to be so therefore
um give them that respect
because
you never know when you may be in that
situation be looked at or belittle
because of who you are so
we gotta adjust our satellite just a bit
and I don't want to sound like the old
dude saying Young Folks anything like we
all have to figure out a way to not
become too used to what's going on right
now and that's just the truth
if you can in your music if you can in
any of your entertainment if you can try
to sneak a message in there I'm not
saying that we that we can stop
everything but we gotta figure something
out